well hello they are watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages as they come in uh it's
time to see what's making the headlines
with the independence political editor
andrew woodcock and the telegraph's
environment editor emma gatten they'll
be with us from now until just before
midnight welcome and great to see both
of you so let's uh start then with the
front pages as ever
and documents seen by the eye indicate
the government believes the uk will have
largely stopped feeling the effects of
the pandemic by
2023 or 2024
the times leads with calls from the
prime minister boris johnson for the
french president emilio macron to block
migrants crossing the channel the daily
mirror has claims that the duchess of
sussex told an aide that her husband
prince harry was constantly berated by
members of the royal family over megan's
relationship with her father
the daily telegraph hears of government
plans to lower the threshold at which
students pay back their loans
and the sun speculates over the romantic
lives of the england footballer jack
relish and the actress emily attack
so let's uh bring in our guests then uh
emma and andrew uh we're here in glasgow
let's start with that waiting until
eight o'clock tomorrow morning we're
told andrew indeed i mean cop 26 may
well be the most important event going
on in the world right at the moment but
it's not dominating the front pages
tomorrow for a very obvious reason
that's because it hasn't got to result i
think all of us when we came here we
thought the deadline's 6 p.m on friday
that will never be hit
these things always go to the last
minute because everyone always thinks
there's an advantage to be gained as
long as the negotiation is going on
we're hopeful it'll finish tomorrow but
uh there's no guarantee of that and the
question emma everybody we will be
looking at is is it watered down is it
weakened are there elements that are
more ambitious what's given up by one
nation to get something back the sort of
the horse trading that's still happening
tonight here yeah absolutely we've
already had one revision of the draft
text and so we'll be looking tomorrow
for those key elements on fossil fuel
phase out and coal phase out to see if
they're still in there and what it means
for whether countries will come back
next year with new targets
well that's the big question will they
there seems to be pushback from that
possibly from china
a real sense that they want to get on
with it in their own speed for example
uh but let's take a look at the guardian
it's it is made the front pages but in a
in a smaller way has it not um the
question really is can alok sharma bring
nations together to keep the world on
1.5
still no deal as the deadline passes and
1.5 degrees is absolutely critical the
question is what do they need to do and
is this idea ratcheting up to bring
people back year on year the way to do
it well the delegates and officials i've
spoken to over the course of the day
today they all seem fairly confident
that there will be a deal of sorts
tomorrow it will be a deal which will
allow alexander to say that the the hope
of 1.5 as the maximum increase in in
temperatures average temperatures across
the world that that's 1.5 will be still
alive but it won't be guaranteed at all
and i think the probably the most
significant thing to come out of the
whole deal will be the speeding up of
the ratchet mechanism the idea that
instead of every five years as was
agreed at paris
that every year countries will have to
come back and improve their um offers on
um emissions reductions because
the paris deal was supposed to take us
up to sort of you know 20 30 45 of um of
emissions gone
20 30 isn't very far away now and if you
don't do it year by year you've only got
two five year gaps between now and 2013
in fact less than that and it and indeed
the emissions targets of the nations
show that by 2030 there will be more
emissions and not a 45 reduction which
is which is obviously not what was meant
to happen on 2010 figures um but fossil
fuels has been a key part of this hasn't
it the debate about whether that line
should be kept in saudi arabia we know
wants to take it out there has been a
suggestion that it was put in as a
bargaining chip and actually it was one
of the things that we're going to be
jettisoned but now foreign thinks of
course it should be in there this is
about getting rid of fossil fuels and
coal and now people want to keep it in
there is that is that your understanding
yeah and actually this is this is
somewhere where the uk has really been
able to show leadership because they
that was a the in the initial draft that
was pulled together by the uk presidency
they put it in there almost as a kind of
an optimistic punt really and they
weren't expecting it to make it to the
final draft um but it has made it to the
second draft and then what they are
saying is that actually when they have
these conversations countries are
talking about this and countries are
saying actually we do want to see that
in there in some format in the final
text which would be precedent setting
for one of these summits absolutely it's
not been there before we'll see if it
hangs on in there in the documents
published at eight o'clock in the
morning in terms of the money the big
issue here has been money as well for
effectively multiple things for
mitigation which is getting rid of the
emissions for adaptation which is
dealing with the effects of of climate
change and also for loss and damage
which in some people's mind like america
could mean
effectively reparations a never-ending
bale of this is what you did to my
nation you know what where do you see
those three elements fitting in for many
of the poorer countries here are
desperate for help as we've heard
throughout the summit well there's this
concept of loss and damage it's a new
one really here at this summit and it's
not one that the the rich world has
entirely taken on board and the idea
being that you can pay people or pay
countries rather to adapt to the
possibility of rising um sea levels of
more frequent hurricanes and more
frequent floods and so on but the loss
and damage which they suffer from an
individual event can be absolutely
massive it can take up you know a vast
proportion of a small country's gdp
and the argument is that um it's the
rich world that caused the um
the the problem with climate change and
cause the extreme weather um and that
they ought to be making some sort of
reparations for that and if you look at
what happens then that could be
absolutely gigantic bill and we're
nowhere near getting that agreed at this
summit
well they can't get the hundred billion
dollars that was promised back in 2009
can they they're looking at maybe what
96 billion by the end of 2022 possibly
the 100 billion dollars a year promised
from the uh the rich nations to the
poorer by 2023 which is a long time to
wait when many you know the plaintiff
please from people here we're feeling
the effects right now to the mat cartoon
um never want to shy
uh
can we water down blah blah blah um
emma there's no doubt the youth movement
has had a very big impact but they're
not here doing the negotiating right now
no and it's really kind of amazing
because it's almost a two you know a
two-track process because you have the
protesters outside and they're dealing
with a sort of different um a different
world than the the negotiators that are
inside this bubble and the the reality
for the negotiators is just just so
different they're dealing with the
political boundaries of what their
governments will allow them to do but
you do need to have
the activists outside who are putting
the pressure on those people inside to
go that little bit further
and it is the later generations who will
be impacted we saw franz timmermans
who's here for the european commission
holding up a photograph of his grandson
and saying how much of the earth will be
livable in by the time he hits
40 years old and this is where we're at
isn't it now that 1.2 is in many places
causing havoc what does 1.5 or 2.4 do
which is the latest prediction from
climate action tracker based on the
promises made at this summit
well i was speaking to one of the
delegates earlier today who said that in
this discussions around the table a lot
of ministers from all over the world are
now saying this is what my children are
saying to me this is you know in
discussions at home they're saying to me
dad you've got to talk mum you've got to
sort this out because this is the world
i'm going to live in and we've seen you
know it's 1.11.2 now we're already
seeing
quite remarkable extreme weather events
um 1.5 will be worse than that but um
you know the experts tell us that that
is still livable um
2.4 degrees which is what the um climate
tracker um
calculation is that the the pledges from
from this summit would actually produce
that it's very difficult to imagine um
you know lives like that and i think
france timmermans has made a very strong
point talking about his grandchild
actually in a position of having to
fight for food and fight for clean water
which is is sort of unimaginable from
the state the position we're in now yes
global instability and human conflict
you know you don't know where it ends do
you but there's been progress hasn't
there there's been a change in tone
business the corporate world is here
they're ready to fund the green future
and in terms of temperature too before
paris people said it was going to be six
by the end of the century then four
after paris and now or in the realm of
two so for you
as as somebody who deals with this day
in day out what is the progress that
this is already delivered
i mean what people who are inside these
negotiations and have been at one cop
meetings for you know decades will say
is that they never imagined that they
would have got to where they're getting
now that they would have kind of brought
china india saudi arabia to the table to
discuss what we're discussing here so it
has made a huge difference you know but
you know has it been enough that's i
think a different question well we'll
wait and find out when we 8 o'clock
tomorrow morning then they'll talk some
more then they'll talk some more
and then by the afternoon we might see
if the gavel goes down on what has been
a very interesting two weeks where you
know the world is really reliant on many
parts of the world really reliant on
what they hear here and whether they
come back again next year
to again as they put it ratchet up
people's pledges that they do should
move on to the pandemic i mean there's
parallels out there the uh the
scientific revolution that came with the
pandemic can it be used in climate but
the eye
revealed when the uk predicts the
pandemic will end
an exclusive they suggest white holds
three scenarios for when public can
forget about covert 19. uh some might
suggest suggest the government is
already hoping we feel like that but uh
what's your assessment of this andrew
well it's interesting i've not seen
these these um dates before if these are
official predictions i think people will
be fascinated to to see them you know
the idea that we
covid could be a routine disease by the
end of next year
on the best scenario but on the worst
scenario we could still be struggling
with in 2026 if you know if i presume
that that would be the scenario where
you've got some
new variants somewhere which which get
round vaccines and the idea that we're
still
um you know having
lockdowns and other mitigations you know
five years hence is something that make
people shudder i think yes and certainly
tim spector who's done so much work uh
on his zoe app and get in terms of
people giving uh their symptoms it did
suggest it could be up to eight years
didn't he but let's have a look then
optimistic prediction uh sees the virus
become routine disease in late 2022 or
23. a most likely situation is the world
will escape the shadow of covet in 2023
to 24 and the uk officials believe with
vaccines testing and antivirals
preventing new lockdowns and the
gloomiest forecast is for mass
infections to continue until 2026
but that's considered highly unlikely
you know medicine's coming on all the
time antivirals we know the uk has
signed up to
testing we hope will continue some
suggest that we need to be paying for it
some at some point uh vaccines as well
we're already into um you know third
primary jabs and boosters aren't we
is that going to be it every four months
we get another jab
i mean i think everyone's everyone's
hoping for that aren't they it's kind of
like you want it to become just a kind
of routine thing that you don't have to
think about so much i mean being here i
think the kind of pandemic has been very
present at the cop26 summit as well
because there's been so many measures
that they've had to put in place that it
becomes you know almost overbearing
really so i think for that would be kind
of good news but yeah 2026 is a is quite
a gloomy outlook yes indeed yes a daily
lateral flow test for everybody in the
building moscowing at all times and as
we heard in the plenary today there's
too many of you in here some of you will
have to leave or sit in your seats did
you hear that so i mean it's been
difficult and there has been a sense
here that people feel that it's not been
as inclusive as promised the uk
government had promised it would be an
inclusive summit is that because people
can't get into the rooms and is that
partly because of the pandemic well that
must have had an effect i think i mean
it's it has to be a limit on the limiter
on the number of people who can be here
um i don't know to what extent that has
has been the the cause of people being
left outside or whether that's a
security issue
um i mean going around the um the center
you do see a lot of activists a lot of
people from ngos from third parties who
are here to raise issues and not to
actually be involved in the negotiations
and i think um you know i've spoken to
some of the organizers um
of the um the cop presidency and they
say they want the people here who are
making these um noises who are demanding
change because they're representing the
people outside and they're um
there's it's an important reminder to
the the um the politicians that um this
is uh something that really impacts on
ordinary people and which really
concerns ordinary people and to be fair
boris johnson turning his attention away
from the cop 26 summit too covered today
real concern across europe um
specifically the german speak some of
the german-speaking nations about how
cases are are rising
and whether we once again see an optic
in cases here that they had been falling
for many days
yeah absolutely and obviously that's
what we are all sort of fearing might
happen that we would have to come into
another lockdown especially with
christmas approaching and what what that
could mean for all of our kind of
festive seasons
there we are again talking about
christmas we can't we can't go there oh
sleaze something i'm sure uh the
tory party are watching very carefully
because it's having an impact on the
polls according to the daily mail andrew
yes there's quite a remarkable poll on
the front page of them of the daily mail
today after
week well months and months of uh
comfortable leads over labor willing
into double figures only only a few
months ago and after being at three
points in the lead last week um boris
johnson now finds himself six points
behind labour in this poll
now of course you always have to take
these sorts of things with a grain of
salt because it is always the case that
the
most interesting polls are usually the
ones that are wrong because they're the
outliers but it certainly it shows a
direction of travel that um is very
concerning for boris johnson and for the
tory party because
these sleaze allegations clearly are
having an impact um it's two weeks now
almost that um there's been virtually
nothing on the front pages apart from
cop and sleaze and
series of allegations and i use the word
allegations in fact some of them proven
facts that
that conservative party and mps had been
paid for lobbying and so on and that the
prime minister attempted to cover it up
and attempted to to effectively neuter
the um standards commission um which
which looks into these things in
parliament or just earned a lot of money
for a second job at a time when
everybody else at home is finding the
cost of living gas prices you name it is
on the way up and it's that sort of
contrast isn't it for for many people
despite that boris johnson has been
until what looks like now the kind of
teflon prime minister
yeah we've seen reports that concerns
over taurus leads are the highest that
they've been since the 1990s which is
obviously going back you know that's
overshadowing even the expenses scandal
so it's not looking great and it has
been sort of dominating the headlines
even when boris johnson came here to
glasgow he we faced a lot of questions
about this
uh quick word then on this story megan
shockley royals constantly berated harry
uh this is further revelations in the
court case with the about the mail on
sunday yeah i think this just goes to
show that um the long-standing tradition
of the royals not going to courts to
fight um
uh privacy cases or or cases of um you
know inaccuracies in the orders they see
them in the press that that tradition
was a very wise tradition i think as
soon as the royals are in the court
regardless of the rights and wrongs of
the case what happens is that um
the details of their their private
discussions of their their intimate
lives become the fodder for public
discussion and some would say that's a
great thing if the royal family is
opened up to the um
to the scrutiny of the public but uh i
wouldn't imagine that the royal family
are among the people who think that no
indeed so as the details emerge it's day
two isn't it of of jason canalf and uh
the revelations from him uh emma gatton
andrew woodcock thank you both very much
lee we'll see you shortly for more